[Musique]
qui vient en aide aux personnes dans le
besoin se sont vu remettre les clés de
leur nouveau locaux ce 13 janvier à
Saint-André les anciens ont été ravagés
par un incendie le 15 décembre dernier
cachant les fêtes de fin d'année
grâce au département l'association
dispose désormais d'un local de plus de
800 mètres carrés
c'est un nouveau toit que nous offrons
un moment papalella pour son action
d'être social d'urgence pour un nouveau
souffle il disposait d'un local de 350
mètres carrés il dispose maintenant d'un
espace de 820 mètres carrés donc
l'activité d'aide sociale en faveur des
plus démunis va se renforcer va se
développer grâce aux partenariats
renforcé entre le département et mon mon
papa lela j'ai une pensée émue et pour
Monsieur c'est Patrick Savatier j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire de lui rendre hommage
comme d'autres au moment de son décès et
j'ai dit que son action va se livre qui
n'est pas mort parce que il vit à
travers ses actions aujourd'hui nous
passons de la parole aux actes Patrick
tu vois que ton action continue à vivre
ce nouveau local va permettre aux
membres de l'association de poursuivre
leur activité une remise de clés forte
en émotion pour ce nouveau départ ça va
nous permettre de nous poser je pense
l'aménager un peu mieux que là où on
était c'était bien mais c'était petit
vraiment là on a un espace pour
l'atelier un espace pour le stockage
oublié un espace pour l'alimentaire et
les champs froides donc
ça va nous permettre de mieux d'être
mieux organisé une reprise d'activité
espérer le 23 janvier après avoir
déménagé les quelques meubles qui ont pu
être sauvés des flammes lors de
l'incendie
[Musique]